These won't come
[inaudible], you're here with Greenpeace. You're in Scandinavia with Greenpeace
[inaudible] and the thing is that you've been working a lot with them.
You've been traveling with them, uh, and you've been twice, I think,
in the Arctic, uh, on the boat. Yeah. Uh, how,
how do you fit in there? How do you, I mean, how is it, how do you, um,
London with the crew.
Climate change,
I think is the pointed end of what's good of our problems at the moment.
And we've really got to get, we've got to act so fast to stop it from,
um, from reaching, you know, two degrees.
So I joined Greenpeace to really go and see for myself, you know?
Um, and I, the thing is, it was the first time that as an organization,
they'd really taken a breath.
I'm sorry to even use that word, but she's so offensive,
but this first time they'd taken an actor, you know? And, um, so I thought,
I think, well, I knew as soon as I got on the boat,
I took one look at their faces and I knew they were just thinking, Oh God.
Awesome.
[Inaudible] 14 year old daughter. We got to put up with that.
And they're all rugged men and women of the sea, you know, they're not,
you know, I mean.
Do you know what I mean? I mean that
they're all covered in oil.
That's a lot of chains. And anyway, um, it's very sexy actually. Um,
but, but the captain of the boat, who's Russian leather mirror.
When I come on board, he said, um, you, you can, uh,
you can clean the toilets. So I said,
okay. I said, doll, you're on.
And I clean those toilets every morning with such a passion. You know,
that by the end of it, they all said, you know what? This has been great,
but our toilets will never be the same again, you know, it's, uh, it was, um,
it took me two weeks to break them down. Do you know what I mean?
But we got there in the end, extraordinary people, you know, all of them,
great activists, people who go off on six months on these boats, you know,
and they really know their stuff. You have to be a sea person.
It's very impressive. I love this organization.
Uh, due date. Do they, I mean, are there any perks for them,
for the crew to have a movie star board or.
No, not really. No. Well, I mean, you know,
I tend to do,
I do a sketch show at the end where I do do them each one and actually on the
last tour, we had an Argentinian first mate and, um,
called nacho who's for some reason or other kept on playing Rocky
music. And that he was a great fan of Sylvester Stallone,
which was slightly unexpected. This was,
of course the versus alone is a very right-wing and, um,
a trumps anyway. So I happen to know him. So,
um, yeah, so the end of the tour, I rang him and said,
would you please send me a little video message for my friend nacho?
So he turned this and he,
I've never seen a big burly bloke who could, you know,
barely look at me. I mean, it was,
he fell to his knees and cloth my ankle,
and then sent it to about a million people in Argentina. It was very funny.
So that was, I suppose, that that's more as a perk. Yeah. It just one.
Uh, so this, this alone is not the only, um,
only right-wing man with success to put it that way. I mean, you have now,
uh, one climate skeptic, uh, in the, in the white house.
So it it's going really well for, let's say your opposition these days. Yeah.
Don't forget in the white house,
there's quite a lot of division already cause Ivanka and Tillison have both come
out and said, we can't miss the Paris agreements. You know, so this is good,
but actually one of the reasons that I'm here particularly in Scandinavia is
because there's something very interesting going on in Norway because
Norway it's always, always, always been a kind of green beacon for me. You know,
it's a great that they've done so much for green climate change against climate
change,
cleaning up their act before anybody else I've always had great admiration for
the country. And in 2014,
they wrote into their constitution,
a new article and it's so beautifully written.
And it's about the protection of the environment for future generations.
And it is it's wonderful.
Were there very few countries in the world who have such a thing in their
constitution? So it's new and it's, it's fabulous.
So they put this in to the constitution and then went to the Paris agreement,
signed. It,
came back and handed a new oil drilling
license to start off.
So there's a whole new oil frontier in Norway.
So they sort of did one thing with one hand. This is the Norwegian government.
I'm sure the Norwegian people would be very much against it if they knew really
what it entailed, what it meant for our people, for the planet,
but doing another thing with the other hand, I think it's a very immoral act.
And I think it's probably having put that article into the constitution.
I think it's probably illegal. So Greenpeace are taking, um, with another, um,
organization, um,
are taking the Norwegian government to court and also district court in
November. But now we've got Trump. He is,
my mother calls him in the white house. She's 84.
She comes in and every night to have her glass of wine. And she says,
have you heard what Trump has done today? And I say, mom,
don't be so excited about it. It's not good news. She says, I'm 84.
It's not going to affect me. So we don't have a.
Way here or Norwegian government at least, uh, to, to,
to sort of defend themselves. Uh, they will in court, uh, I guess,
uh, but, uh, we don't have Trump either, but let's say, I mean,
he watches a lot of television and let's say he helps me out once
Donald Trump. Yeah.
You want to hear it?
[inaudible] let me do well. Okay. I'll tell you the story. It's very funny.
I was doing, um,
primary colors drawn to Volta in Hollywood and, um,
I was in my trailer and it was on the universal lot and my,
I had just been divorced and my decree Nissan decree absolute had just come
through like the day before, which was no big deal. It was just anyway.
So the phone rings in my trailer,
which has never done before I looked at it and it's like, weird.
It's like a moose has just entered my trailer. I'm just,
what are you doing anyway? So I left on the phone. Hi, it's Donald Trump here.
I said, really well, can I help you?
He said, yeah, I just, you know,
I wondered if I could for you some accommodation. And one of my Trump towers,
they're really comfortable. And I said,
why are you offering me somewhere to stay in my trailer?
I don't what, well, you know, I think we will get on very well.
Maybe we could have dinner sometime.
I didn't know what to do with myself. I was absolutely. I was on my own.
And I just said, okay, well, I'll get back to,
uh,
[inaudible] never met him before. I'd never met him.
Never met him since I've never met him since. Or you didn't, you didn't do this.
You didn't meet.
You could be the first lady. Yes
[inaudible]. Do you know what I did think about afterwards? I thought,
I wonder if he's got a kind of list of people who were about to be properly
divorced, like, you know,
a list of people who might look good on his arm or might give a little bit
something, you know, to the Trump brand. I just wondered whether,
because it was just so weird. Did you ever.
That's an explanation how your number get the number in the trailer?
Universals.
[Inaudible] but he could have been a liberal,
he could have turned them around the history of the world.
I hate when that happens,
when you had an opportunity to change the whole history of the world and you
just missed it.
Yeah. And like you, you have, you kind of always been an activist through your,
through your life. Uh, what triggered that?
Well, I was doing standup comedy, um, you know, like in C and D marches.
Oh no. [inaudible].
Yeah, a lot of comedians in my country.
There's this thing called alternative comedians in the city.
You remember in the seventies and eighties? Yeah,
because you were about 12 aren't you you're very young. Yes,
it is. It is a compliment. It really is.
But I'm sort of in the seventies and eighties,
we had the alternative comedians who were all very, um,
they were kind of prophetic, actually a lot of them, um, about what,
what was going to happen politically. Um,
and the labor party and the left were full of comedians doing their shtick.
And, um, I did a little bit of that, um, before I became a Knight.
So I didn't start acting until I was 27. And, um, and so I,
I talked to a lot of comedians,
so it was through there that prison. And like you say,
they have a kind of Tourette's,
they just say stuff and they see it because comedians are so
clever. I mean, not you obviously, but, but they are,
they're really, they're always so bright.
And they're always thinking about things in a different way.
First of all, what if you, I mean, working as a standup comedian, what was,
what was the, the joke that worked best for you?
What was the killer joke for you? Do you remember?
I do, um, this, this joke,
generally speaking, worked quite well. And it was about, um,
the fact that my boyfriend had come back from
some holiday or rather, and gave me an STD,
which is called thrush, which is, um, candida, you know,
and then down there, it's something it's a woman's problem. Yeah. Yeah.
This is cool. You get it in your vagina
down that it's in your vagina.
It sees a kind of bird as well, but it's not the birds.
That would be really young.
You want to give you that?
Right? Well, that's the whole other thing anyway, this not the joke.
The joke was that. And you might not, I don't know whether you even hunted this,
but in those days you would treat this disease with
plain yogurt, live yogurt, because the bacillus, you,
you can have this joke for your act
because you do real jokes about real things. And this is,
[inaudible] heard this, uh, Oh yeah, that's true. But, um, anyway, it's so good.
It's just so not funny now, plain yogurt.
So you would do per tampon into plain yogurt and push it up your vagina.
And this would make, this would balance the healer candidate.
So I had sent a friend out to get some yogurt and he'd come back with tropical
fruit and nut flavor.
[Inaudible], didn't move to Hollywood. Although you have the,
you have a huge career there, you have two Oscars, five nominations, right?
But you never moved there. No. Why not?
Cause I CA I couldn't. Can you imagine? I mean,
every time I have to go to Los Angeles, I think, Oh God,
I'm too fat to go there. That I'm not going to, they're not going to let me in.
Hello. You're Emma Thompson. You can't come in. You're too fat.
Now look at you. You're fat and you're old.
Are you trying to hide the fact that you're old? Well, you're not.
You're all in your fat go home. I mean,
I really like feel LA is so mad. And so, um,
so hostile to, you know, that actually,
it's not true when I go there. They're always very nice to me.
I'm really just doing a gag, but at the same time, at the same time,
it is a very strange place. And, um, it, it, I couldn't live there.
I could live here. I loved it.
[Inaudible] or, uh, of, of, uh, Hollywood.
It's not only in Hong Kong all over the place. In fact,
you know what I want to do? We lose it with me. So we want,
we should bring out a pro aging, cream, everything on it.
It's just written anti aging, anti aging, what is wrong with us?
We are all going to get older.
Why are we doing this anti aging? These like, yes.
And climate change. I get that. But why would you,
it's everywhere for men, for women.
I even got a question from one of your journalists from England.
She asked me once, how come you're not as thin as other actresses?
And I was just so shocked. I just said, Oh, I,
I just think that's a boring question,
but what I really wanted to say that I thought.
About later, I want you to say, Oh,
I think wondering about that.
Why are everybody in the American movies I listened
to? I had no idea. I said the same thing to another one. I said,
did story, do you want me to be an actress or a mobile? Yeah. What do you want?
And also the anorexia, there's so many kids,
girls and boys now, and actresses who were very,
very thin who were into their thirties, simply don't eat.
They don't eat. So if
it's such a huge subject, isn't it really should do the next,
your next big documentary on it.
Because there was a wonderful actress I was working with on something called
Bryce, had revisited. And the producers said to her, will you,
will you lose some weight? She was absolutely exquisite.
And I said to them, if you speak to her about this again,
on any level, I will leave this picture. You are never to do that.
It's evil, what's happening. What's going on out there. And it's getting worse.
You know, the French fashion industry said, yeah, yeah, yeah, we will,
we will get rid of size zero. And then, you know, it,
didn't not only didn't, but just continued to, Oh, God is so boring.
Oh yeah. Oh.
So sometimes there are some subjects you just have to make noises about because
it's so tedious and it's gone on and on. And when I was young,
I was writing comedy absolutely about this. I wrote a sketch about, um,
the best diet that you can do, which is auto cannibalism, where you eat,
do we then an optimum body weight.
So in the sketch you have I've come on and I've got what was a bit of my butter
on a plate. You know, that I've cooked,
but unfortunate I'm a little bit over on balance.
I'll have to hold the weight in this hand, in order to stack the fries.
I was writing about this when I was 21 and it's still terrible.
But someone told me once that, uh,
the reason for David Beckham's immense popularity around the globe was that is a
good footballer. And it's really handsome,
but it didn't have any opinions because once you have opinions,
you divide opinion. And how has that been for you?
Because you've been really outspoken. Has it been easy for you to just do.
Not very popular? Absolutely. I mean, quite recently,
um, I was a press conference in Germany when,
just before the referendum about Brexit, a journalist said,
should we leave the European union? And I said, Oh, don't be ridiculous.
Of course we shouldn't leave the European union.
We're a little rainy cloud covered
teeny cake, eating pilot, and we need your good heavens.
It's absolutely wonderful that we can just put off and go to Europe.
It's there's sunshine and French cheese, you know, and,
and all of that, I mean, so I was doing a gag, you know,
and I got home and the front page of one of the tabloids was shot your K.
Cole.
Big, big group, you know, because the,
the sort of very right wing press were going, what do you mean?
How can you describe our country? And this is in this negative light, actually,
I would say that what I said about England being rainy and cloud bolted
and cake eating is absolutely true.
But I would add two words in February because actually it's true.
It's really true in February. Always say what you mean,
and then you won't have to, you won't have to be thinking,
which lie did I tell about that? You know, which lie did I say?
Which thing that wasn't really what I thought did I say in order to keep on the
right side of this group of people, that's, um, you know,
that's for politicians to play at,
but not if you're going to stand up for the things that you believe in.
Emma. Uh, if, um,
let's say that you got another chance of the Donald Trump called you up today
and invited you for dinner, would you, would you say is so tempting?
It is, isn't it.
So tempting just to just go suddenly, just to sort of say, look,
it's so nice of you to.
[Inaudible].